it's almost universally accepted now
that spoilers are bad we seem to hate
them I've personally seen multiple
people in theaters clamping their eyes
their ears shut just to avoid a movie
trailer and the culture of spoiler
avoidance seems to have reached new
heights what do you think of the season
finale Game of Thrones but I don't want
your sorry anecdotal evidence I want to
know what science says about the
question of whether or not spoilers
actually hurt our enjoyment of stories
because what if I told you that studies
have shown that spoilers might actually
make you enjoy a story more think about
it knowing the outcome of a story
doesn't prevent you from enjoying it we
routinely re-watch and reread movies and
books and adaptations and remakes can be
enjoyable experiences so maybe our
intuitions about the negative effect of
spoilers are incorrect goodness knows
science has proven society's intuitions
wrong in the past thank you so much to
Skillshare for sponsoring this video
in 2011 Jonathan Leavitt and Nicholas
Kristen Feld from the University of
California set out to test the actual
impact of a spoiler on the enjoyment of
a narrative they had 819 participants
read short stories from a variety of
genres some unspoiled and some spoiled
and then the participants ranked their
enjoyment of the story and surprisingly
they found that people enjoyed the
spoiled stories more so what's going on
here to figure that out we're gonna have
to dive deeper into the science of why
we enjoy the things we do we can call
getting a positive experience out of a
piece of media media gratification let's
look at three theories that attempt to
explain why we find media gratifying
according to enjoyment appreciation
Theory the gratification we get from
media is a combination of the enjoyment
we get from the creation and the
resolution of suspense and the
appreciation we have for how the media
moves us emotionally provokes thought or
from the aesthetic qualities of the
under this theory it seems the spoilers
would reduce enjoyment by eliminating
suspense but they might actually
increase appreciation by taking our
focus away from what's going to happen
at the end and allowing us to focus more
on the artfulness of the story
throughout I've experienced this effect
where I've enjoyed a movie more on a
rewatch because I was less focused on
how it was going to end and more focused
on the individual craft of each scene
the transportation theory of media
gratification claims that our enjoyment
of the media comes from its ability to
engross us and transport us into the
world of the story
spoilers could affect transportation in
a few ways on one hand researchers who
have studied transportation have found
that stories are more transporting the
more familiar you are with the work we
can hypothesize that a spoiler might
help you be more familiar with the story
and therefore aid transportation but on
the other hand researchers also found
that stories are more transporting when
they're more suspenseful and again
spoilers would seem to reduce suspense
finally we have processing fluency the
theory that media gratification comes
from feeling like you understand and
comprehend the story after their 2011
study Levitt and Kristen Feld theorized
that spoilers benefitted the narrative
by increasing processing fluency
spoilers may allow readers to organize
developments anticipate the implication
of events and resolve ambiguities that
occur in the course of reading but in
their 2011 study they only had
participants rank the stories on a
simple 1 to 10 scale so while they knew
that they enjoyed the spoiled stories
more they didn't know what type of
increased gratification the participants
were getting so in 2013 they conducted
another study to test if the positive
effects from the spoilers were coming
from processing fluency and aesthetic
appreciation and they found in their
experiments that the benefit of the
spoilers did come from an increase in
processing fluency the more complex the
story was the more positive effect the
spoiler had so even if the spoiler was
the stories ability to generate suspense
the increase in processing fluency was
enough to produce a net positive gain in
gratification they did not however find
the spoilers to have any impact on the
participants appreciation of the
aesthetic qualities of the stories but
you're probably like well no no I still
no spoilers are bad I had this thing
spoiled for me one time and it was
terrible and maybe you're just an
anti-science
skeptic and probably a flat earth or two
fine spoiler alert
these studies might be wrong any study
needs to be replicated and in 2015
that's just what Benjamin Johnson and
Judith Rosenbaum set out to do Johnson
and Rosenbaum brought in four hundred
and thirty participants and had them
read short stories both spoiled and
unspoiled but this time they had them
rate the stories along multiple
dimensions that would measure enjoyment
appreciation and transportation and they
found basically the opposite of what
leva and Cristian felt found in their
studies when it came to both enjoyment
and transportation probably like you to
expect intuitively the unspoiled stories
were enjoyed more than the spoiled ones
and spoilers seem to have no effect on
appreciation so what's the takeaway here
we have two studies that seem to
indicate that spoilers can increase
gratification and one that seems to
indicate that it decreases gratification
well a key element is that all three of
these studies are measuring
gratification in slightly different ways
even though Johnson and Rosenbaum study
measured gratification in a more complex
and nuanced way they still left out
processing fluency which is what Levin
and Kristen Feld found to be the whole
reason for the benefit that comes from
the spoilers so it would make sense that
they didn't find any positive benefit
from the spoilers if they weren't even
measuring for processing fluency and I
can see other reasons why these studies
might not tell the whole story
all three are measuring the impact of
spoilers on short stories and you can
imagine that it might not be that
upsetting to have a short story that
you're reading for a research project
spoiled but having the major plot twist
of a TV show your 25 episodes into
spoiled could be very upsetting and more
recent studies seem to confirm this a
follow-up study from Johnson and
Rosenbaum in 2017 used video clips from
movies and TV instead of short stories
and they also conducted a survey to
measure if gameofthrones viewers who had
seen spoilers enjoyed the show more or
less and in both cases the spoilers had
a negative or statistically
insignificant effect on overall
enjoyment they also measured for
processing fluency this time but their
findings contradicted Lovett and Kristen
Feld's findings about processing fluency
and another study by Thomas Daniel and
Geoffrey Katz in just August of 2018
found that spoilers had no effect on
short stories but did have a negative
effect on full episodes of TV I think
they do a good job of summarizing some
of the limitations of these studies in
their conclusion it's possible that
participating in an experiment such as
this participants are not as invested in
the narrative as they would be reading
or viewing for pleasure there's a lot
more research that can be done and a lot
of variables to be considered such as
how major or minor is a spoiler is the
context in which the spoiler is
delivered and the amount of time that
passes between receiving the spoiler and
consuming the media and it's obviously
important to measure what the
participants mean by enjoy and as
accurate and nuanced a way possible but
the fact that these studies don't
immediately confirm our intuitions about
spoilers and when they do find a
negative effect find it to be fairly
minimal or non-existent as very
interesting to me and I think we
probably overestimate how important it
is to avoid spoilers the plot twists
aren't often the most important parts of
a good story and I've had many things
spoiled for me that I went on to totally
enjoy and while a spoiler might
eliminate suspense it can potentially
create it as well sometimes a plot twist
or a character death is used as a
surprise or for shock value but if you
have that spoiled for you the suspense
of waiting for that moment not knowing
when it's going to come or
what's going to happen can be very
intense I've experienced that myself
and I'd like to see studies that test if
different people value different types
of media gratification I wouldn't be
surprised if some people place more
value on processing fluency or some
people place more value on
transportation versus enjoyment and
appreciation these differences if they
exist might explain why for instance
critics can love the movie and general
audiences hate it or why some people
actively seek out spoilers and enjoy
them and others don't let me know in the
comments below which type of media
gratification you think is most
important to you I'm not advocating
intentionally seeking out spoilers
I think avoiding spoilers is totally
reasonable but maybe you don't have to
stress about it as much and if something
is spoiled for you don't write it off
there's a chance you might even enjoy it
more this video is sponsored by
Skillshare Skillshare is an online
learning community with over 25,000
courses it's a brand new year and this
is a great time to learn a new skill
that could help you further some of your
goals people occasionally ask me for
advice about making video essays and my
main advice is to just do it and if you
want to do that you can check out Sam's
course for making video essays Sam that
lend over production makes some great
educational essays and this course walks
you through some of the basics that
could help you get a handle on the
process I've taken Skillshare courses
and voice-over and audio and
cinematography and logo design and it's
all helped me a lot making this channel
Skillshare is giving away a free two
month unlimited access trial to the
first 500 people who click the link in
the description box and after that it's
only $10 a month it's a new year so take
that next step to stay learning and
become a new you thank you to all of you
for watching I want to thank especially
Devin Bray for becoming my first $25 a
month patreon supporter if you want more
information about becoming a patron of
my channel go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]